[Musique]
je suis dominique anglade une mère de
trois enfants québécoise d'origine
haïtienne je suis également ministre de
l'économie de la science de l'innovation
je suis la fille de deux haïtiens qui
sont venus s'établir ici au québec en
1969 mon père georges anglade est un des
fondateurs de l'université du québec à
montréal en géographie et ma mère une
militante féministe une économiste qui a
également été enseignante mireille
neptune de mon père j'ai beaucoup pas
pris l'engagement politique
l'implication sociale
le fait de vouloir contribuer à quelque
chose qui est plus grand que nous
quelque chose qui nous dépasse et de ma
mère j'ai j'ai appris la rigueur et j'ai
aussi appris l'importance de s'impliquer
auprès des groupes de femmes auprès des
gens et de trouver des moyens de
travailler avec elle pour qu'elle puisse
s'épanouir
lorsque j'avais peut-être dix ans ma
mère m'a raconté une histoire que je
vous dirai jamais en fait m'a posé une
question et on a dit dominique est ce
qu'il existe quelqu'un de plus prouvé
que l'homme le plus pauvre au monde dans
le pays le plus pauvre
à cette question j'ai dit je vais
probablement pas et m'a dit oui oui mon
amour sa femme est probablement ses
enfants
cette histoire m'a beaucoup marqué sur
la question de la femme est l'importance
de regarder les inégalités entre les
sexes ici mais partout ailleurs dans le
monde
pour moi ce qui est important c'est de
transmettre ces valeurs qui m'ont été
transmises par les parents à mes trois
enfants
c'est de poursuivre cette aventure
humaine pour moi la famille représente
d'abord et avant tout une encre une
encre qui te permet de revenir à la
maison de te sentir bien de reprendre de
l'énergie pour mieux pour mieux
conquérir le monde par la suite en moi
c'est vraiment cette force
incontournable qu'on a besoin d'avoir au
pouvoir faire plus à l'extérieur de la
maison
[Musique]